all of us are trying to get through this
the best that we can
and we're finding ourselves making
decisions we might not make otherwise i
understand that you've been
fostering a dog you've been taking care
of a dog
temporarily is that true oh my god
what's his name yes this is tommy this
is tommy
he's a little old man
but he's like the sweetest dog ever yeah
um
you know i'm home all the time now
usually i'm working and traveling and i
can't take care of a dog but um yeah i
had a friend reach out i was not
planning on having a dog that day
and then the next thing i know i i got
this guy so if you go to uh
at wagmore um if anybody's
interested in adopting little tommy i'm
going to have him until he finds a
forever home
okay i mean look at this look at his
face oh look at that guy
you know what i have to say he doesn't
look thrilled to be seeing me uh
his face kind of fell like oh that one
that
that hop that host huh all right okay
so uh i want to get the word out because
if someone's out there who would love a
sweet
uh older i would let's just say mature
a mature dog he's mature yes and and
it's at wagmore
mm-hmm wagmore yeah just
m-m-m-o-r yeah um and he's yeah he's a
sweetie and he's
very low-maintenance you know he's he
doesn't he doesn't do a whole lot now
except just want to be cuddled and said
and yeah so if anybody wants a little
tommy he's here
yeah i'm telling you as someone who's
quite a bit older than you that happens
later on
yes i want to be cuddled i want to be
held
uh occasionally dragged onto the porch
to take care of whatever i have to take
care of
and then drag back in again that's
exactly right
that's pretty much my life